[Musik]
hallo
heute zeigt ist ganz einfach wie ihr
futter selber herstellen könnt euch auch
mal passiert dass sich die butter zu
hause aufgegangen ist und dann
entwickelt die flugbahn hilfreich wenn
man weiß wie man fotos selber machen
kann und deswegen sogar einfaches rezept
ihr braucht nur eine sloothaak und dann
zeige ich euch auf treiber reaktionen
und zwar habe ich hier einmal eine
kräuterbutter mit kräutern aus meinem
eigenen garten haben wir einen tomaten
butter und einem kilo salz butter und
will fangen gelingt einfach mal gleich
not eine selbstgemachte butter brauchen
wir nur eine zufahrt und zwar ist das
sammel also ganz normales schlagsahne
und das kennen wir auch wahrscheinlich
weniger schlagbar damals belange gehört
habt dann wird sie so ein bisschen
glücklich und da entsteht einfach mutter
jetzt gibt es verschiedene methoden ihr
könnt einen mixer verwenden ihr könnt
dem handrührgerät verwenden oder ihr
macht ganz einfach so die ist hier ein
großes strafbefehls da waren wir
schattenmorellen oder dauer kirchen drin
und das habe ich es ausgewaschen
da kommt die sahne rein und damit ein
bisschen einfacher geht und auch
schneller habe ich die sahne einfach auf
zimmertemperatur kommen lassen und ist
auch echt ein tolles rezept vor allem
für kinder
da kann man wirklich sagen komm komm wir
machen jetzt mal selbst gemachte futter
und auch wirklich gerne er während der
schulzeit gemacht und habe dann einfach
mit meinen schülern genommen brot
gebacken und dann haben wir eben noch
butter hergestellt
jetzt habe ich das hier und jetzt müsst
ihr einfach nur noch schütteln und im
ersten moment entsteht damit schweizer
schlagerstar und dann kommt von moment
wo man einfach da steht und macht mal
plump und das ist dann der moment wenn
co2 entsteht
und jetzt könnt ihr euch vorstellen wer
bei uns zuhause dieser tätigkeit ausüben
darf sagt es nämlich der rat
was macht deutlich dass der borat mai
bringt der spieler seine mutter machte
peter und es war auch wirklich ein sehr
aufwendiger vorgang als mutter allein zu
machen ist nicht auf endlich aber das
ganze dann halt gemacht
warum soll dann die buttermilch flaschen
und bhutan und smarte fall früher
einfach gebucht wird
und vor allem ist selbst gemachte butter
viel viel günstiger abgekauft und das
ist oft viel leckerer ihr seht jetzt
schon ganz komisch aus ich hab ich schon
butter länger als eine minute
jetzt noch ein bisschen und der
butterflocken ist das futter die
flüssigkeit ins boot am ist auch zu
warten
jetzt sehe ich die butter und geht jetzt
hier das entschied damit die buttermilch
athleten kann rassistisch
ich habe nicht länger als zwei minuten
geschüttet
sie könnte jetzt richtig gesund weil
santa monica ein ende da habe ich diese
also die fertigung rückstände der sahne
während die klassischen tanz und jetzt
jetzt mit großen glasschüssel ja du
kannst trinken
musik gemacht oder video und in die
glaskugel habe ich jetzt wasser gegeben
und heißt würfel
russland und wenn ich vorher in dieser
kräuter rhein geben würde
das gleiche war hier ist die butter
rhein bis jetzt nämlich so freese dann
ist er zu warm um schmerz und jetzt das
1,6 nähten und die restliche butter
minister zu sagen auswaschen und somit
leicht die butter auch länger haltbar
das heißt sie bleibt etwa eine woche im
kühlschrank haltbar und ansonsten ist
eben nicht so mein haltbar und wird auch
schneller
[Musik]
naja es kalt kalt null grad
wahrscheinlich glaubt die frankfurter
als sechster von links stellen wir nicht
auf twitter her
deswegen stand ford nicht auch mal
furchtbar vermissen die regale rumlaufen
im kühlregal wahnsinn
echt cool
[Musik]
das kneten im iphone ist übrigens
einfacher wird es vorher in einen
gefrierbeutel gibt denn dann kommen die
einst nicht in die bütt zu betreiben
[Musik]
fertige butter ich habe jetzt insgesamt
auf 500 gramm sahne etwa 180 gramm
butter bekommen das heißt man bekommt
etwa aus 200 gramm sahne 70 gramm butter
also immer ein drittel
das werde ich jetzt weiter verarbeiten
also soweit die butter ist erst mal
fertig ihr könnt jetzt in die schöne
form treffen oder einfach ganz klar als
in form pressen und ich zeige euch jetzt
drei varianten ich mache nämlich eine
formaten butter salz philipp kutter und
eine kräuterbutter und dann habt ihr
wirklich drei verschiedene futtersorten
und können sie zum beispiel auf brot
streichen oder auch beim grillen
verwenden hier vorne sind die zutaten
für die tomaten butter brauche ich 50
gramm tomaten maß und vier televisa
einen halben teelöffel zucker eine prise
pfeffer sechs betrieben blätter
basilikum und eine viertel knobloch sehe
für die salzburger brauche ich ein
viertel das nächste meersalz und pfeffer
chili und für die kräuterbutter habe ich
dir kreuzer der wahl auf meinem hof des
oregano durchschnitt lauf basilikum
petersilie und dann auch ein viertel
teelöffel salz und etwas pfeffer
ich habe jetzt zuerst mit der tomaten
butter und dafür nehme ich jetzt die
basilikumblätter da nehmen wir einfach
so viel wie er gerne möchte
die knoblauchzehe raus der rest kommt
jetzt schon montiert so thome das so und
hier ist ganz wichtig dass zukommt
reinkommt es gibt einfach den tomaten
geschmack und 100 vor allem die säure
perfekt ab und die rezeptur also die
kräuterbutter rezepte und tomaten butter
rezepte könnt ihr natürlich auch mit
gekaufte buch machen aber schmeckt viel
besser mit der sätze machten die
basilikumblätter werden jetzt fein
gehackt und die knoblauchzehe davon
brauche ich nur ein viertel
die werde ich fein dazu schreiben
[Musik]
münchen
mehr
seite und kann jetzt die kräuterbutter
machen und darf er nämlich jetzt reuters
wir werden jetzt auch fein gehackt und
dann wird alles zurück
[Musik]
mit
dort können
[Musik]
und die butter geht ganz einfach nur
salva chili und sehr menschlich kann
hier natürlich auch ganz viele andere
kräuter verwendet
[Musik]
die fertige butter habe ich den pfiff
als folie gelegt und dann mit hilfe der
frischhaltefolie zu einer rolle geformt
und wir da die beiden enden rechts und
links einfach ein bisschen zusammen
viertel kommen sie auch wirklich schön
in form und so können sie dann in den
füllstand oder auch wenn er hilft den
schrank stellen
ich habe die folie am ende dann noch
entfernt und habe jetzt die butter
einfach in pergamentpapier eingewickelt
und so findet sie im kühlschrank etwa
eine woche lager im gefrierschrank auch
ein bisschen länger aber länger
würdigste ganz lagern wenn die butter
schmeckt wirklich frisch auch
allerbesten und das ist jetzt wirklich
die perfekte mutter morgens beim
frühstück oder auch nachmittags zum film
oder einfach auf fleisch und vor allem
wenn wir eingefahren ist habt ihr den
vorteil dann können wir beim könig zum
beispiel immer schneiden unter schneiden
von der rolle und die dann einfach auf
fleisch oder eben auch auf dem gelegen
ich bin die mutter wirklich super lecker
vor allem wie tomaten boot mein favorit
danach folgt die kräuterbutter und nach
chili salz butter gibt ein bisschen
einfacher aber will ich auch super super
lecker und der vorteil von west ihr
machte futter ist dass wir eben auch
immer stressig ist das heißt ihr könnt
sie eine schüssel geben mit einem deckel
drauf und dann ist wirklich aus dem
kühlschrank heraus richtig stress wesen
und ich würde mal sagen stellt euch in
die küche holt euch ein schraubglas und
ein schlag sei aber ein becher
schlagsahne und macht einfach auch mal
eure setzt gemachte butter vielleicht
hat hier auch noch ein paar rezept
variationen für mich gefasst was wäre
die nächste boot hatte ihr euch wünscht
die nächste super kreation und ich
wünsche euch ganzen spaß nachmachen und
vor allem viel spaß beim verzehren und
wir sehen uns das nächste mal
[Musik]